à l'étranger une rencontre au sommet
entre Vladimir Poutine et le dirigeant
nord-coréen Kim Jong-Un est arrivé en
train en Russie ce matin c'est très rare
et là il y a l'étranger la rencontre
pourrait mener à un accord permettant à
la Corée du Nord de fournir des armes à
Moscou pour soutenir les Russes dans
leur guerre en Ukraine je ne sais même
pas où il fait fabriquer ce truc qui
date de 1935 ou 50 il y en a plus
c'est comme les qu'est-ce qu'il va faire
en Russie alors ça c'est la bonne
question
c'est pire que la terre c'est pire que
la SNCF regardez un sondage récent on
demande aux Français est-ce que vous
vous allez bien
ça date du 30 août dernier sondage est
là oui moi je vais bien 65%, 70 %. parce
que la France va bien non elle va mal
70% il y a un truc qui va pas dans
l'autre
[Musique]
ont été réalisées sur des patients
atteints d'un cancer du poumon
métastatique au bout d'un an 44% de ce
traité avec le vaccin thérapeutique ont
survécu contre seulement 27% pour ceux
qui ont reçu chimiothérapie un
traitement prometteur ça paraît
déroutant mais regardez ce que les
chercheurs ont réussi